professor rolf pfeifer ist leiter des
robotik programms an der universität
zürich er ist initiator des neuesten
roboter projekts der schweiz robbie ist
das resultat dass ich hier für mich ein
botschafter für eine neue generation von
robotern die minister roboterhand
motorenklang
und velemir aber wenn sie muss
kassensystem studieren habe ihren
roboter entwickelt wobei muskeln und
sehnen hat und mit motoren frank
schumann oli dorothee die meisten
versuchen vor allem menschliche
bewegungen zu imitieren
anders bei den haushaltsroboter klein
und kompakt sorgen sie für ordnung im
alltag
komm wir machen andrücken im kino werden
beweglichkeit und helfer funktion oft
kombiniert wie im film robot entfernt wo
sich ein pflegeroboter um den dementen
frank kümmert die beiden werden freunde
und mit hilfe des roboters beginnt frank
wieder seinem alten zwielichtigen beruf
nachzugehen
und einer stunde und 43 minuten
das ist perfekt
manche kinder sehr viel verschiedene
tätigkeit der musiker befinden
aber eigentlich will man das wirklich
der falsche nicht so wirklich gut um für
sehr viele tätigkeiten dieser maschine
oder schneller besser billiger präziser
und ohne ihre musiker vierter der mensch
kommt an seinen grenzen schon 1936
parodierte charlie chaplin die
überforderung des menschen in der
arbeitswelt
abhilfe schaffen da ganz andere wesen
industrieroboter
unermüdlich schuften diese stählernen
giganten tagein tagaus für uns menschen
oder ihr gegen und
es war natürlich sieht das kurzfristiges
waren jetzt in einer bestimmten
fabrikautomatisierung
arbeitsplatz verloren weil man aber wo
kompetitiv sie auf dem internationalen
er dann nur es mathematisch ihres gerade
höhere automatisierung um jeden preis
experimente in einem stuttgarter
altersheim führen zu begegnungen der
dritten art
hallo ich bin care o bot 3 in dieser
woche unterstütze ich die pflegekräfte
bei ihrer arbeit
ja ich möchte doch bestimmt etwas
trinken
die fünf tiroler wald bewegen oder und
ich finde auch quasi physikalisches
bewirken dass ich ein nazi ist
faszination vor dem ganzen aber anders
ist das noch ziemlich arbeit ist vor
allem für die schon gesprochen die
beiden da würden sie die empfehlen der
schalter ist der neue haushaltsroboter
ist da in der schwedischen serie jugend
kann man roboter fast nicht mehr von
menschen unterscheiden ein spiel
zwischen vertrauen und
angst
während einige roboter noch brav am
abend ihre batterien aufladen beginnen
andere gegen die menschen zu revoltieren
ja
und die schöne neue welt wird zum
alptraum
das nicht macht endlich auf sonst
arbeiten vier bald für sie und nicht
umgekehrt
diesen können können wir wohl nie ganz
trauen